Doing design you need to be able to represent those designs and a very popular
way of doing that is with diagrams. This course focused on UML, using UML and
constructing those diagrams and the purpose of this lesson is to review for
you some of the different kinds of diagrams that are there. There's lots of
diagrams, we're not going to be using them all. But I'd like you to be at least
familiar with what ones are there. So let's step back a little bit in history.
Diagrams have been a popular part of software development from the beginning.
I still have a flow chart template that you use for
writing out the control logic of an algorithm. Over the years,
various sophisticated diagramming techniques have developed. Okay.
Among those are SADT, Jackson Design, Structure Design and so on.
Each with their own particular approach to diagramming. In the 1980s, object
oriented tech, techniques began to emerge, and with them. Various techniques for
diagramming [UNKNOWN] solutions. The first one we want to look at is called OMT.